battle the doctor set my parents down
and said my life was fragile perspective
is the game
i guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient hello
what's good what's good what's good i
missed all of you so much
uh i'm so excited to be here um
let's see some of the people in the chat
this is so fun god i missed all of you i
hope everybody's super well good morning
max what's good
good to see you rudy branch lily p s
soto
great to see you uh great to see
everybody alex
um great to see you pokemon radar what's
good
hey saab great to see you thank you for
joining big shout out to everybody on
twitch
facebook youtube linkedin twitter
and instagram dustin how are you this
morning
good just kind of forgot how to do
things
yeah a little rusty right yeah a little
rusty too
um great to see you though and uh hope
you've been well you make some money on
some sports cards
or pokemon no money just more inventory
just buying yeah that's good
interesting ones oh nice little work so
you're getting deep you're getting
educated
trying i mean these two i'm not really
sure hey you're gambling
yeah a little bit of a gamble but the
yellow cheeks the red cheeks you got any
of that
yeah i got i got a red cheeks on the way
it's it's coming from canada though so
it's not going to be here for a while
but red cheeks nine or
yeah nine i can't tense
i get it anyway great to see you let's
get into the show cool
yo yo what's going on gary
things are good man what a what a
background bro yeah i'm over in
capri italy i i uh i flew into croatia
and once you're in croatia for two weeks
they they kind of accept you in other
places so
is that is that the rule yeah that's the
rule over here so you know i'm i'm
i'm scrolling clapping begging any
anything to travel you know i love
travel so
bill i really wanted you on the show
everybody i really wanted bill on the
show
um because i think his uh topic of his
new book is super fascinating
i think it has a lot to do with
happiness um bill why don't you take the
platform for
a quick second and make sure everybody
follow bill why don't you actually why
don't you give two seconds of context of
your career and then
a little bit about your book okay so uh
context of my career i started off as
assistant assistant assistant assistant
peon on the new york mercantile exchange
that means i snuck sandwiches on the
floor for traders
uh meanwhile i was learning everything i
could uh became like a journeyman
got better and better uh became
basically made sure i was like
irreplaceable got an opportunity to
trade at a desk in houston texas
worked at a hedge fund started my own
hedge fund do investments
made movies you know became a rich guy
did what i thought rich guys
things should do and um now i'm
have daughters family ex-wife
engaged kids dog cat you name it i got
it
um you know just trying to find balance
in my life and live my life and enjoy
life and i wanted to share some of the
things that i've observed that i think
people can get
fulfillment from so what's the name of
the book and what kind of uh
what was the uh what was the blueprint
the book is called
die with zero you've got it on you i'm
impressed bro
i'm impressed yeah comment i come
correct uh it's called die with zero the
book is
it's a it's a it's about net fulfillment
over
net worth and really it's a methodology
the message is a methodology for
everyone to look at their life from now
to the grave right and use all their
resources
at the right time to get the maximum
they can out
out of life from a happiness roi versus
how much is sitting in the bank account
from a fulfillment like
how do you define it like am i supposed
to be happy am i supposed to be like
enriched like what's the perspective so
i i believe that the summation of your
experiences and the experiences you
choose to have
and when are correlated with your
happiness and your fulfillment
right so i solve for those experiences
and making sure that you know you go to
work right
part of it is you love what you do i can
tell that you love what you do getting
your message out right but part of it is
to pay the bills for survival we need to
survive
and then the rest of it is for
experiences that we want to have
and a lot of times people become
successful they go on autopilot
right and they're just like success
piling in the money and they're
forgetting they're going through life
like they're driving home
right and you just all of a sudden a
home you don't you don't remember how
you turned you took or anything you're
just home
and boom you're 74.
you've got some dollars in your bank
account but did you love what was it
great
question correct and i want people to
have uh
the biggest ride they can have and the
experiences they choose so i want them
to get off autopilot
i want them to recognize that their body
deteriorates their their mental
facilities deteriorate
and certain experiences are meant for
certain times in their life
so is that similar to you know a lot of
people get mad at me when i talk about
high-risk behavior in your 20s
because it's just more practical to you
know go for the three or four you know
so many kids at 22 are like [ __ ] i have
to get real now
it's over and i i've really struggled
with that because i'm gonna know this is
exactly the time you do
whatever you really think you want to do
because the regret
is devastating and the practicality of
doing it now while you've got four bozo
roommates
versus versus a husband and two children
or a wife and three children or
responsibilities you know i've always
been fascinated
of 22 to 30 years old i think people
completely misplay it
it i've really focused on that range it
seems like you're focusing on a very
similar vibe
in the macro yeah i'm taking from that
22 to 30 and i'm taking it all the way
to the grave and i 100
agree with you on taking i always tell
people
think of the most risk you can possibly
take in that time frame and then add a
little bit more
yeah i agree with that i you know my
risk
and bill it takes all shapes and sizes
my risk was i knew in my brain
and my chemicals that i was a beast but
i also
desperately wanted to [ __ ] come
through for my parents because i loved
them so much i was so grateful
you know it was so entrenched in me like
where they grew up both of them lost a
parent
at a young age you know they grew up in
russia and i
and i knew i had it and so for me the
high risk was
build a humongous company for my dad
from 22 to 32
to and have nothing and start over
that's risky
other people's version is they've always
wanted to be a rapper and they just need
to go to the south side of atlanta and
go
for it instead of getting a job at
goldman sachs or
like you know going to grad school
listen i i
people even when they fail in those
ventures they are enriched they learn
from that experience and they have so
much more to add in their relationships
in future professional endeavors etc
bill what about for the people that
are not destined to be rich but
also want to be enriched and have this
like so talk to me
real quick for the 98
that are going to make 70 to you know 48
to 130
000 a year you know from a resource
standpoint
what can they get out of this hypothesis
because obviously they're going to have
different like you know your background
right now is something people are only
going to see
and they're like not lived because
they're not going to have that financial
capacities potentially how should they
be thinking about it well let me
let me work backwards on that one thing
i say to people everywhere i go every
exotic place i go there's somebody doing
it for one one thousandth the price
they got backpack they're couch surfing
they find a way and they're having a
very rich experience too
they're not having this exact same one
i'm having and by the way i apologize i
really apologize
but you just fired me up because i'm
just thinking here i'm like you know i'd
rather go to some fancy place
like like my i'm so dirt that i'm like
yeah like i'd rather go somewhere and
prove to myself that i can [ __ ] sell
fruit but then if i like surfing i don't
like surfing but like i'm like oh i want
to surf
here well i'm just going to go and
[ __ ] bleed and work some [ __ ] job so
i can surf in the mornings to your point
i may not roll up in a [ __ ]
yacht and surf but i'm still going to
serve gary one of the most liberating
things i did was panhandle on the street
as an experiment
i i you know it was it was humbling but
it also freed me was like
i can make it when did you do that i did
it about
five years ago in vegas uh
it was yeah it was about five years ago
in vegas no
maybe six in vegas and it was scary it
was humbling
uh you know i eventually would give the
money back to other people and say hey
just
help somebody else down the road because
i didn't want to be taking money you
were testing the
what i do with garage saling like i go
in garage sale
but then like whatever profits are made
i'm trying to show everybody how to do
it but then i donate the profits
i get it yeah and so so for the people
you know life still you have resources
and you still have choices and you want
to
and when you have limited resources you
want to allocate them properly
throughout your life
you don't want to be delaying
gratification until you're 75 on certain
experiences
when either you won't enjoy them as much
or you won't even want to do them right
like
i don't like you know i'm not you know
you wake me up to go to a club and glow
stick and i'm gonna be like i'm going to
sleep
you know when i was 22 all you have to
say is hey there's going to be girls
i'm up i'll be there in five minutes
right you know and or
you just can't do it right you just
can't like you can't climb match repeat
you at 75 you don't have the watts per
kilogram of energy you need
to get up those steps right and so we
don't want to be making mistakes
in allocating when we have these
experiences and so
i think people will get a lot of value
out of making sure
that they time bucket their experiences
and not have a bucket list that means
hey i'm not i don't put things to go
climb out of earth i don't want to climb
out iris even though david goggins is
trying to get me to climb out everest
after i have kids you can't go spend two
months you know when you have toddlers
on the side of mount everest getting
getting acclimated and so when you look
and you get off autopilot and you think
about the totality of your life
why you're saving right you're saving
for these experiences
so we want to make sure we put these
experiences in the right right time
frame
if you were in heaven and god said hey
here's your resources and you can have
all these experiences but here's the
trick you got to get the order right
a lot of people are on autopilot not
getting the order right not
not not you know not doing the things in
their 20s when they should be in their
30s 30s 40s
50s 60s 70s and when you take a step
back and think about the totality of
your life and you order these things
right you're going to get more filament
you're going to get a better ride
relative to you know you just being on
autopilot and not
getting this message in the book i don't
know you don't have to buy the book you
just need to get the message and i think
a lot of the messages
overlaps with what you which you
optimize for you optimize
a lot in people in their business or in
their marketing and you're the master at
that
this is kind of like a high level total
life
optimization you know it's funny i
really love that because i i
really met you know optimized for
happiness too i mean you and i had a
quick chat about sports cards like yeah
i want to be happy
a lot like and so if i am getting if i'm
talking about garage selling and
flipping if i'm talking about sports
cards or if i'm talking about wrestling
or the jets
a lot of people come at me in high you
know and you run in these high circles
as well of like
hey man you could be like the guy why do
you talk about all this dumb [ __ ]
like you could be floating in rarefied
air what are you doing with all this
stuff and i'm like
i'm being happy and that in essence
that's what you're talking about
yeah it's like getting what you want
like i don't tell people
what to do i just give them a
methodology to get what they want
you know and then they make the choice
framework right yeah
yeah and it's so it's the biggest what's
the biggest thing you've learned
a lot of people watching right now are
inevitably on a track to eventually
write a book or want to write a book
self-publish or go with a publisher
just for fun while i've got you before i
move on biggest thing you've learned the
biggest insight you've learned from the
book process
and tell everybody i mean obviously it's
available on amazon is it out what's the
date it's coming out what's the
punchline
it's out the book is out there it's
everywhere barnes nobles amazon
you know name it independent bookstores
if if they're open
you can get it right and what's the
biggest thing
i think the biggest thing i learned um
is to start
with the outline you know i think like
people like oh i got to do this i got to
do that once you start
and you go through the process of like
hey i'm going to outline this book this
is what it's going to be
i'm going to reach out to people to help
me if you you know you need help
if you're here for your first time you
need help reach out for expertise
but the biggest thing i learned is i've
been talking smack
about this philosophy and this
methodology for like
10 years i'm going to write a book i'm
going to write a book finally my doctor
was like
and then it was going to be an app i was
gonna make an app to like teach people
to do it and find my doctor's like
no you gotta write a [ __ ] book i've
never heard
anything like this and it was a straw
that broke the camel's back because i
was procrastinating
so the biggest thing is to start and
then reach out for help he was like hey
i know this person that's an agent or
this person
that does writing they'll help you with
the outline et cetera start
[ __ ] start [ __ ] start don't be
like me
who procrastinated you know in that spot
but yeah executing mothers
yeah executing others you look handsome
the background looks amazing
i hope you're well and i hope everybody
picks the book up
pull it on the screen one more time some
people visualize it thank you very much
is it are you literal with it is the
punchline of the book like hey don't
have money in your bank account when you
die leave a little something for your
kids like what's the punch line
well it's definitely listen the kids are
extremely important and i'm about
maximizing my kids lives too
and the time you want to give your money
to your kids is not when you die
not a 60 year old right there 28 30
that's when that's going to have the
maximum impact on your life if you're
going to leave something to them there's
some people like i'm not giving my kids
anything but like
for those that are if we want to
maximize the impact so
it's called deliberate living and
deliberate panning all the way and yes
it's impossible to get to zero and i
give you all kinds of methodologies to
not waste your life working for money
that you're never gonna spend
but it is about using all your resources
while you're here on planet earth
to convert them into the experiences you
want so we want to get to zero so we
have zero regrets
die with zero regrets i love it have a
great day bill take care
thanks for having me of course before we
go to our next guest just want to um
give an enormous send of love and
compassion to all our brothers and
sisters in beirut
and lebanon just horrific
horrific visuals yesterday and just um
just my hearts and prayers go out to
everybody uh and anybody who's got
friends or family
in that beautiful city let's keep it
moving
alex gary how are you good to see you
good to see hey man uh oh i can't
believe i'm not
on call with you right now um i'm glad
to have you on
yeah uh so in the back i mean i've been
following you
for a while now you know or we met in
2018 in miami
right and uh you had inspired me as one
of a few real estate agents at the time
with a drock following me around
documenting
editing producing and you told me he
said alex you just wait and see
in a couple years you're gonna have a
whole team behind you
and so i really took it to heart and you
know fast forward now
we're in 2020 in the middle of pandemic
and um
i took my real estate business i joined
a partner with a venture backed real
estate brokerage called side
here in silicon valley and you know
just like you said now my business is
supported by a team of people and a team
of amazing people so
first off thank you thank you you're
welcome what can i answer for you
so besides model is uh it basically
empowers
top producing agents by taking their
their best interest at heart
and so they take successful brands
centered around the agent
rather than the brokerage and these big
box brokerages have failed to do this
for a very long time
i got it yeah and so i mean with you you
know you're
perfect david and goliath story right
wine wine you disrupted from the outside
um same thing with vaynermedia and so my
question to you is like
as the gary vee of of real estate
for my company you know um what is
what are some tips and strategies that
have helped you disrupt the traditional
markets
and for how why is it so important to
have an outsider perspective
to an industry like real estate when
it's like when it's long overdue for
evolution
and change i think the thing that's
always helped me is that
i have a couple things going for me one
is patience you're not going to disrupt
anything i mean vaynermedia is in year
11.
you know i've really run it for nine
years first two years were more aj
i was still doing the wine stuff and
writing crush it so you got to take the
long game
you know side is not going to you know
disrupt all these big names sotheby's
remax
you know keller like it's not gonna
happen tomorrow it takes
a decade two decades three decades so
first
i've always had the long game in mind
that's one
two you know the weirdest thing about me
um that i that me my team or my best
friends or family
always laugh about is the garyvee thing
has so
become a thing that there's a lot of
people that don't realize
who gary vaynerchuk is right like the
person that is actually you know i
haven't done tea with gary vee
and you know i've done it once and every
two weeks lately because i'm operating
you know
nobody's watching me when i'm on the
phone right now at 8 30 in the morning
you know 8 to 8 30 in the morning with
you know
major executives in dubai or from a 30
to nine when i'm having a finance
meeting
and making decisions on you know re
restructuring our
our debt and you know they don't see the
operators so i think the
you know the other thing that has made
me disrupt the wine and marketing
industry is
actual operational talent like genuinely
being a businessman
not playing one on instagram right and
so i think
you know there's a and it's really
worked for me in a lot of ways like
you know i feel like people continue to
underrate me you know i i can't stop
talking about sports cards right now i
don't know if you ever grew up
collecting those alex but
yeah you need to get re-educated two
years ago
i tell every one of my friends and i'm
talking like my brother
and tyler and lou and ryan harwood from
gallery media group and david levy who
i've done business with
and like and sam ben ruby people i've
made money for in investing
in companies and i told all of them to
get into sports cards and
nobody did they they dabbled but nobody
went hard
and it's because i'm actually still
underrated
you know like you know like there's the
the part
that has allowed me to disrupt is actual
skill
like and then being really the next part
i would say is being a culturally led
ceo you know to disrupt you need
continuity
you need the same people around you you
can't spend all your time retraining
and i think that one of the things
that's really worked for me is i build
families
i've built family at bay at face
at vaynermedia and at um at wine library
people that are there for 8 12
15 years and that matters so having
compassion and empathy and being a true
leader
so you know i think and then i think
finally
and by far the most important reason
i've won is
i'm 100 consumer-centric
you know what you plan on disrupting is
like hey karen you're a great agent here
in dallas
you're paying way too much tax to these
logos
you should be making more of the money
because you're the winner
you know it's listen it's run through my
mind in the last two three years
four years of like oh if i launch vayner
you know real estate and i take less
commission
and i build a machine to build up
everyone's personal brand i will win
so you know i think i think that whoever
brings the most value vaynermedia
is doing a lot more for craft and pepsi
and ge and chase
and and diago and on and on and on than
what our competitors are for the same
amount of money it's not super
complicated
uh wine library sold wine at a better
price for customers
and had better customer service and so
you know i i think i think it's that and
then i think
um and then when you layer the fact that
i've built a personal brand and bring a
lot of awareness to the things i do
and even the way i've built the personal
brand in a lot of ways i myself
undermine my own quality because of the
hyperbole the high energy a lot of
people aren't sure sure if i'm even real
or not
um and so you know i i think
i think those are kind of the
ingredients when you ask that question
that come to mind
awesome so you said personal brand and
so i mean
you've always you always talk about
attention tension and eyeballs right
and knowing that in the future and i
remember you talked about how like in
the real estate industry
because so much money involved and such
a low barrier to entry
that it just attracts a lot of c players
right and so
um as a brokerage of the future i want
to we want to develop in you know focus
on developing the a players
and so um well how do i when what are
what are some opportunities that you
might see in in for this to grow
and change and evolve as we build up
leaders uh particularly in this like
coveted times
with marketing and branding and just
kind of what what advice do you have
there
my advice is actually to stay the course
but to cut out
non-potential a-winners along the way
so that you hold up that equity
you know the biggest vulnerability you
have if you actually mean building the a
leaders is not taking the money from the
obvious c d
players right
that's the actual answer yeah that's the
truth
that's the actual truth and that's hard
for a business that you know
has the ability to take money from dnc
players right
so i think that's a discipline thing on
your end
awesome alex i'm rooting for you brother
good to see you again hey gary good to
see you too thanks so much for the time
welcome
peace dustin linkedin not live
i don't see linkedin comments um i saw a
couple before
but let me check hey
big shout out to everybody uh big shout
out to everybody
who's in the comments uh who's in the
share squad let's take this url and
share it
we're firing on all cylinders this
morning um
i love it share oh nice share squad
dustin
uh let's move on to the next guest while
you're trying to figure out linkedin
adam good morning i didn't know they
were going to have you on this that's
what's good
man how are you i think we're supposed
to do last week which actually this week
worked out perfect i'm happy man thanks
for having me before we even get to your
question tell everybody about your
remarkable coffee that we love so much
well uh yeah so thanks for having me on
i really appreciate everything you and
your team have done for us you guys have
provided so much guidance
thank you and once you guys return to
the office in the city i can't wait
yes our awesome coffee so i started
aficionado 2007.
uh my career first off i i've always
been an entrepreneur or self-starter
my mother taught me at a very young age
i remember following my brother's
footsteps as well you know
doing things that weren't so kosher like
selling fireworks and
and fake rolex watches in high school
and whatnot but you know i i believe
it's something that you're
you're born with adolescents absolutely
so
starting finance left my career in 2007
uh moved home with my mother and started
roasting coffee on her barbecue
before you go anywhere how did you have
the humility you know i'm listening to
you right so you're
a hustler kid you it cliche
you're one of the you know some people
go right into building their business a
lot of other people
are so in the thought they don't even
realize yet that they love
the game more than money but they think
they love money so they go into finance
you realize oh this is this is just not
fun compared to like doing some [ __ ]
how did you have the humility to move
back in with your mom was it
forced because you just had no money
because you were spending it on dumb
[ __ ] or were you like i need a reset
well i think for me you know let me back
up it's
i come from a well-off family my mom's
always worked really hard provided for
us i lost my father when i was 18.
and for me the hardest thing was coming
out of college all of my buddies working
in finance you seeing them seeing them
kill it
um and then you know we started to see
some things within our own company in
2007 where the financial market started
to collapse
so i'm like [ __ ] it if i'm gonna take a
risk do it now and yeah it was hard you
know it was
it was not easy to put my head at rest
at some nights on some nights you know
you think that people think that you're
crazy or like
maybe you're a loser because you're not
following what
your path is supposed to be yeah for me
i always um when i worked in finance
i didn't like the status quo like you
know you make money you buy a rolex you
buy a
range rover you party out in the
hamptons and for me i always like doing
what everybody else
wasn't doing so i wanted this off the
beaten path
life and that's what i pursued and i
found happiness with it and then
you know as time goes on i never my
brother is very successful
we have very different mythologies when
it comes to business he's very
uh dedicated to business models and for
me i'm more
creative creative and i'm like you know
what you do
shovel [ __ ] good and if you do it well
enough you're going to be successful
yeah something when you're creative if
you keep the juices flowing
you're gonna look back on your business
model that you created two months ago
and you're gonna crumble it up and be
like
i'm already five miles down the road so
um we are kind of a disrupter in the
coffee industry
we started our focus yeah we started at
the farmers markets
we rapidly went into wholesale so our
brand isn't really well known
being 10 years 12 years into this um
because we focused on business to
business so we sell to restaurants
institutions like yourself and now we're
at the point
where we want to make the turn and start
going to
uh direct to consumer and for us and did
that speed up because of covid were you
one of the businesses when i hear that
model
like a [ __ ] he must have been really
affected by cobit well you know i think
the thing is
you know starting really early on and i
you know not to
talk too much about my my passive losing
my father at 18 but i
thought the most difficult challenges in
my life have pushed me over the edge to
take
risk and i think that rather than look
at the negatives in life you should turn
them into positives
right so because you dealt with
something way [ __ ] harder and losing
your dad at that kind of age
the thought of covid even though it
[ __ ] up the business in the short term
you're like [ __ ] this
i'm going to turn this this is going to
force me to go ham ham
on ddc yep yeah so like i like to look
at it from like a 50 50 split you keep
the 50
50 that's like doubting you and then you
keep
50 of your family in your back court
that's like they got your back
and so with me that 50 is yeah my family
my friends
and my team my team has been like the
most important thing over the past 10
years
we unlike any other coffee roaster we
don't poach people from within industry
i went out and found creatives i one of
our
our head of research and development is
one of our first chefs peter terzo
super talented uh and i'm like [ __ ] if
this guy can do this with food
you know what he can do with coffee and
not only coffee we started very early on
i know you're into wine i've shopped at
your family store
many years probably spent too much money
there um
but uh you know i have a passion for
wine and what i learned really early on
is that the coffee industry is like
50 years behind the wine curve so i
started you know last year i took my mom
down to argentina with a bunch of coffee
farmers we hung out with agronomists
and we learned that we can apply all
these applications from wine to coffee
to get different flavor profiles and do
all these different things have better
production
and so we've basically looked at the
company as like an onion and peeled back
every single layer and said what is
everybody else doing let's do the
complete opposite
and do it thoroughly and rather than
just talk about it we started filming
all of our farm tours i go down to each
one of our origins
annually besides this year unfortunately
um
and we tell the story so there's you
know there's no [ __ ]
and so we've become like this disruptor
one of our biggest clients in new york
major food group
you know they call themselves the
disruptors of the food industry and
because they do things different and
they don't give a [ __ ] what else
everybody else is doing and and so it's
taught me so much and
yesterday actually peter terzo my uh
head of research development said
you know we've kind of become this
company where at the farm level
you can give a man a fish you can feed
himself for a day the old italian
proverb
you teach him how to fish and he'll hurt
us for a lifetime and that's kind of the
philosophy we always
always followed in addition to you know
company that i love
uh tesla where elon musk is like you
know wall street gave him [ __ ] for not
hiring people from ford and chevy that
you know had years of
uh understanding of batteries and stuff
he's like no [ __ ] first first
40 people i hired at vaynermedia had
zero days
of agency experience zero that's amazing
440 zero because i knew i wanted to
disrupt
and you can't disrupt when you bring in
old thinking and i knew that old
thinking would rub off on me even at my
passionate like me it's still osmosis
it's still
subconscious bias yeah absolutely so i
think that
i'll tell you just really that the thing
that sets us apart as a coffee
roaster is at the farm level i mean we
do all these great things back in new
jersey
at our facility peter's great our
roasting team is amazing
uh but what really sets us apart is on
the farms you know people are like
oh i paid an extra two bucks to the
farmer you know we work with uh native
quechuas in peru
they don't have an understanding of what
is good and healthy for them so
anybody that says they're going to go
down to a farm and and get these when
these people over doing business with
them from year to year one year at a
time
is [ __ ] you need to put in five ten
years you need to build a relationship
i get it i get it and so like when you
look at our videos over the years
every year we go down there the smile
gets bigger and bigger because it
becomes family it becomes real
you're not you're not you're not
transacting you're building
relationships you're not coming for one
year when they have over supply to kind
of
get the best deal you can they know that
you're actually there
absolutely right adam what's your
question two uh so it's two part
right so we're making this transition
right during covic right we're
direct to consumer it's not my
wheelhouse a little nervous about it
my team john michael my cousin who
you've also talked to he got us set up
on
amazon so we're doing amazon we're doing
e-commerce
uh would you recommend because we
are still growing very rapidly in our
hotel we don't have a ton of resources
because we're
have grown organically since day one
would you recommend us putting
our resources into like divving it up
between amazon
and and advertisements through
instagram or should we pick one and run
with it
to drive sales on amazon correct split
it's that 50 50 game yeah because you
don't want to become too one dimensional
on just
winning on amazon within amazon because
it's going to get more competitive
and if you can drive down from other
areas it gives you
leverage to not be stuck in that garden
wall of just
amazon sure and then one last thing so
uh
being the king of content we have a ton
of content it's kind of all over the
place because we have content from the
farm we have content from roasting we
have content from our wholesale
direct to consumer and our instagram we
just started focusing on it in the past
year
it's kind of all over the place but i
like the story
that's more than okay i think the
biggest issue for most people is they're
too romantic
about this ideological cohesiveness
on their social i mean go go look at my
social
if i'm the you know yeah
i might be the most all over the place
it might be a cartoon it might be a
it might be a like a long video it's
then it's a picture there's a quote that
yeah i think yesterday put a picture of
me shirtless in eighth grade like you
know it's like
it's completely all over the place
because it's the truth of the story
i'm not trying to build a [ __ ] art
project i'm trying to [ __ ]
communicate
yeah absolutely well i appreciate it
gary adam
everybody follow him everybody follow
we'll talk to you soon
take care gary take care brother bye-bye
all right let's keep it going
hi gary hi how are you
thank you so much for having me this is
such a big manifestation thank you
you're welcome where are you from i am
in niagara just outside of toronto in
canada
awesome what's cooking um so my question
is a little bit specific so i was hoping
i can give some context for you
i'll try to keep um so for me uh
growing up money was very very hard i
lost three homes from 10 to 18.
i had to get two to three jobs at 15 to
like continuously help out um and it was
a lot of like failure and struggle
um and i had to grow up quickly um fast
forward a bit i struggled with mental
health and was in a lot of dark places
and
up until three years ago it was really
really hard um
and for me like i'm normally such a
positive and bubbly and energetic person
um and anyone who will tell you like i'm
extremely passionate
so it took me a while to get out of that
um but then i found you
and i stuck my head down and started
working on like what i really really
want and what i want from life
and happiness and work and everything
and
i became like the young tall blonde girl
that was like
always working she was at hotels
restaurants bars
and i became a manager really quickly
because i love to lead i love to do what
i'm passionate about and share that with
people
and i developed this love for the
hospitality and events industry
so i went to college for it um and
that's where
everything got a lot more stable for me
i still worked three jobs because
experience was value
um and i found out that i truly loved
what i do and
i kept wanting more i wanted to do big
things so i got involved as much as i
could
um fast forward a couple more years i
got a full-time
job managing a large event venue and it
provided me a ton of opportunities so i
started a side hustle
um so i ended up managing social media
and marketing for hospitality and event
professionals
um and it really like in one year it
took off so quickly
so i joined team teams with uh two of my
bigger clients in events and wine
like you um and now i found
now i find myself like wanting to grow
my personal brand on instagram
because everything's been going so well
i want to share my experiences for other
people in the industry
and as well as i also like i always have
a million projects on the go
um i ended up becoming a manager with
the wine expert and then also now
i'm teaming up with the other client and
we're actually becoming business
partners to start our own
luxury event planning service and i
truly love it all it all makes me so
happy and i love what i do
uh but my question is i have all this
motivation and i
love to work like i work day in day out
um and i wanted to ask how do i find
balance when i have so many passions and
i want to make all of them big
patience okay you know
like you know what you're talking i'm
like oh this is
the blonde woman version of me right
like i also
had all those things that i wanted to do
um
but what i did like what you did which i
admire so much was first i created a
stability
and then at you know 34 i started vayner
to
and the way i looked at it was to build
a platform okay
and now i'm 44 and things like empathy
wines
can happen you know other things will
happen over the next decade and so i
think
i think the biggest issue you probably
have is what almost everybody has
which is when you have ambition it's
awfully hard to also have patience
yeah that's how i feel it's like i want
to do all these things i love them
i feel like for whatever reason luck of
the draw with dna
circumstance maybe seeing
my parents you know just work forever an
event you know like i don't know what
but um i was gifted with
extreme patience and extreme ambition
and i think that i've come to realize
especially in my early 40s now that that
is not as common
as i would think because i had it
and i think that what's hurting you is
your
your own judgment on yourself
yeah definitely that comes from lack of
patience
like give time you're a young woman you
really are
give it time give it time for these
things to manifest and also
understand that one of those three
things may
fail yeah and that's okay
i try to take like you say like failures
is
better than winning sometimes because
you learn so much from it
100 and as long as you give the right
intent and did it the right way
and went about it the right way then
you're in a really good spot it's just
um
you know patience is hard
because it's important yeah i definitely
feel that
people like gary patience is hard i'm
like no [ __ ] because it's the [ __ ]
core ingredient to success
for most people yeah and i feel like
everything for me
was like hard growing up and now like in
my 20s like it just
kind of started going positively so i'm
like go go go all the time
because i'm like because because
hardship in youth a lot of times is a
secret
to success okay
like you're such a go-getter because you
had such adversity
to stability you've created stability so
quickly
because it's what you yearned for
because you didn't have it most people
actually have it as a child some have
too much of it which actually makes them
the reverse of you which is entitled and
soft
yeah definitely i just and i have like
all these experiences and these stories
and i find myself being like motivate
other people and i want to focus on
doing that and want to focus on making
my businesses
matter me too and i've been doing it and
i've been doing it every day since 2006
yes i just need to be patient i feel
myself feeling like rushed all the time
why that's the question i guess
why to whom you know whose affirmation
are you looking for
right who are you looking to say that
you did it
yeah definitely i guess myself like i
just
i genuinely am so happy with what i'm
doing i just have to be more patient
with it
because yeah and take and take a breath
and be like [ __ ] grateful
yeah like here we are right like look
how quickly you've been able to you know
sometimes people with tough childhoods
don't really get to that place to their
40s or 50s which is still remarkable off
of that starting point you've been able
to do it so quickly
you were gifted with talent and you were
trained and circumstanced
into hard work and here we are
yeah definitely and i like i know like
my two businesses with um
my wine client and uh my event company
like i know it can work like i have it
in my head
and it's like just put your head down
for a decade and make them work
yeah and then when you wake up and when
you wake up in six years and you want
more
personal life stuff do that too and then
in nine years when you wanna
after that in 15 years when you want to
get into something altogether
new do that yeah
no rules okay
i love it thank you so much welcome
see ya bye
gary vaynerchuk what is good
buenos dias luna diaz how are you
i'm well i'm well i'm blessed i'm alive
i mean you know
can't complain can't complain what's
your name and where are you from
my name is mahogany nabra i am from
atlanta
i shot my show on twitter and i thank
you so much for replying
welcome yeah i like cried ugly cried for
like 20 minutes that morning
nothing's more fun than me reading my
twitter and just randomly saying yes
you can be on the show or you want to
meet me one day well here we are so
manganina such a pleasure what can i
answer for you all right so just
i'm going to give you some you know back
story just um
same as you immigrant parents upbringing
you know came from up here from mexico
grabbed my mexican shirt today and um
they were just coming you know just like
your parents
trying to get a better life trying to
trying to do better for their kids to
stand a third
and um i just like i still have memories
of like
going out in california collecting cans
with my mom so that she can get the
money for the recycling
yeah i used to walk to kmart with my mom
for five
miles because we didn't have a car
we walked five miles been there like and
i was and i was like super soft i would
like cry and my mom would have to carry
me while my two-year-old sister was just
like
trucking a big shout out liz novello go
ahead
um but yeah so i've always kind of been
like an outspoken person i mean clearly
i'm not shy
so thanks
an epic lipstick by the way you brought
the lipstick game for real
i had to do it with i mean i'm not an
artist but nothing like i'm not gonna
come out here with no
bland looking face
water park that i loved as a kid
anyway go ahead okay um so yeah i
have always been about taking chances
betting on myself and just
[ __ ] going for it um of course as a
kid
and as you get older life kind of beats
at ya
experiences kind of come at him because
we're all born without ability
like i could [ __ ] do anything like
when we're babies we're like i'm the
cutest
[ __ ] thing in this room somebody
caught on me like now
so i i buy that keep going yeah
so um when i was in third grade i was um
one of the teachers we had an assembly
like every elementary they have the
little assembly
things like it was a show uh our it was
our grade's turn and
one of the teachers was like oh my god i
need somebody like i need a volunteer to
do a cheer
and i i was like go go not realizing
what i saw myself up for it ended up
being
me on stage little third grade mahogany
holding a microphone i'm like and i'm
like
talking and then the freaking microphone
dies and it's not even on
the whole cafeteria laughing at me
and i'm like i'm already up here so
don't [ __ ] do the damn thing
i go again and i'm like when i say this
they use this [ __ ] citizenship
the whole like gary when i tell you how
like in love i felt with that moment of
being on stage
to have that response and that influence
in a positive way like
mind-blowing um so i'm
very like it's always been a thing of
mine to be a motivational speaker just
because of all the things i've went
through
later on fast forward to like high
school i got into um art
heavy um not that art but actually
airbrushing um
i my mom thankfully she was more
concerned with my work ethic my
character my dad as well they all they
always my dad
preached interpersonal skills he said if
you are not gonna
get good grades look that's that's one
thing you have to be a good person
you have to be that when you go out into
life
you are a good mother you are a good
employee
blah blah blah yeah so i have so much
love and respect for my parents like
literally
any they just influenced me so so much
and i'm so grateful for them
i um i
i did the airbrushing thing i ended up
getting paid to do other people's
projects um
in school so i um like i still have like
the little
invoices that i made myself i always had
that hustler mentality just i was like
you know what [ __ ] it like i'm more
concerned with making money anyways and
my parents were cool with it so you know
i when you
talk about oh taste during your 20s
you're looking gary at the epitome of
the
taster at the table yes
literally okay so i'm gonna just i'm
gonna go with rapid fire here because
this is gonna be a lot
um left high school tried to do art um
art school that failed community school
that failed
marine corps that failed um went back
and did massage school with the money i
got from the marine corps for doing just
boot camp i know about the yellow
footprints though hey
um after that i just i bounced around
from jobs to jobs
job to job became um a special needs
teacher
legal assistant
you said what now i was saying you were
searching you were talking
yeah my mom kind of got on me about that
she's like you know like
like she got impatient
yeah she's like you gotta pick something
and stick to it
get a job with benefits i'm like oh i
don't want to
so i just you know i kept trying things
i got married like i said
um that was not the healthiest
relationship
and still to this day i um i still
have contact with him or he tries to
reach out to me um
it was an abusive relationship so i will
say ladies
guys whoever wherever you are if you're
in a situation
where this person is keeping money from
you physically hurting you
abusing you mentally physically whatever
make a plan and please i beg you from
the depths of my
soul get out it is not worth it
especially when you have
kids it's my birthday
um and i i think from that marriage i do
have a
beautiful little three-year-old um and
he's tried to reach out to see her but
i'm like
you weren't there for the divorce but
now you want to be there out of nowhere
rabbi um so that's
been a kind of come and go type of
situation i just block it and
keep them moving haters are gonna hate i
mean jesus had haters hello
um
i'm just going off my mind i mean
i knew you'd like me like i love you
why can't i help you like like when you
really think about it where where where
do you want to put the energy
so okay and that's where i'm at now i
left my corporate job not too long ago
about two weeks ago
um literally the week i got i landed
this
um i had prayed about it for a while
anyways because
because of kovid my youngest brother
being special needs
he was gonna need somebody to be with
him to teach him my mom
um isn't able to just because she works
nights so during the day she's
trying to sleep um so i was like okay so
that's
i can kind of do that but then i had to
quit my job so
um i'm doing art now and that's kind of
what i've been pushing
i'm trying to kind of see how long that
can hold me over
um i do have my website uh somewhere
it's just mahogany studios.com
my instagram you can check it out it's
all over the place
we got you all right yeah yeah it's um
it's all over the place but
i definitely um i have other interests
as well like i said i would love to be
in the future like a motivational
speaker and i
understand that i can't divvy out my
energy into six different things it's
just not gonna work
like because there's too many
why what's wrong
and more importantly mahogany what what
are you aiming for because i would tell
you that
you could divvy it to six things you may
not find
the financial impact
but you might end up being wildly
happier
i mean you're clearly an intriguing
individual no seriously in a good way
like you've got crazy energy and like
you know you know when i hear that i say
you could do six things it might look
like the following
you may have one thing that really is
the maximizing
like when i look at you i'm like oh this
is that girl i need to help her
see that if she can get one thing that
is that she likes
that is like the meat the meat yeah
right that's her job but it's not
her obsession she likes it but it's nice
and it's a nice stabilizer she's got a
three-year-old
she has a nice stabilizer she's probably
feeling her own level
of impatience and anxiety like i need
something like that
and then no see that
that i will
well then then your comment of i can't
do six things makes no [ __ ] sense to
me then
no hear me with me hear me out
you're more than welcome to do mornings
with mahogany but this ain't it
so okay because i'm coming with real
love here for you oh yeah i really want
to hear you out though seriously
you can do six then if you're actually
truly patient
and you're actually happy well then you
can do 63
like for real because you've decided you
can't
on six but i don't see it
because you don't have the other
variables that make people struggle with
that
i i think you can why not because
your mom said so because you are tired
like what i feel like because i wanna
basically because kind of like
back to where you were saying about um
it being like the meat i feel like i
want to give
important so much 100 into everything
and i'm not going to be able to
like for example for like the
motivational speaking i put up videos on
my instagram
um for the art like i have my website i
king actually did my website by the way
um so that was awesome um
and for uh september i'm actually
starting real estate school
um so that's something that i'm going
into doing with my brother um david
so yes
um to do to do real estate i mean
spanish speaker
in atlanta like there's the hispanic
population is so under
underserved down here can i ask you what
you're what you're solving for
do you think about your world right now
like first i need to get a financial
stabilizer
like is that at the top of the list um
it's up there but it's not like the
biggest so what's the biggest
the biggest i mean and see that's the
thing like the biggest
is like a long-term goal that i know is
not
to retire my parents that's awesome
that's lit and that's what i'm saying
like i know that's going to take a while
and even
okay so keep going with me got it that's
phyllis that's more philosophical
which needs practicality cool so what's
what's next
what's the next the next biggest i'm
just
like getting my own place cause like
right now i live with my family um
so far both of those sound very
stabilized in money
right so like when i go is the first
thing financial stabilization
both your first two are byproducts of
what i was trying to make number one
like that's why that's what i'm saying
like money is like that's why the money
is like such a like
long term like it's gonna come i know
it's gonna come
it's gonna come if you execute there's a
lot of people that get to 89 with the
money never came
because they never went operational
now now you may be happy forever which
is [ __ ] huge
i'd much rather you be 92 and happy
forever
then get to 63 get your parents into
retirement
but not be happy no yeah and
that's um like especially now that i'm
getting older like i always told myself
like oh yeah like i don't want
to look back and have like my daughter
be the reason
i didn't pursue my goals or she slowed
me down or this time and third and
you're no she she's she's definitely not
like
good news you're you're too thoughtful
the fact that you even put that out in
words means that you
have the energy to not allow that to be
an excuse because here's the problem
there's just unlimited single moms that
went on to destroy it
so there's you know that is definitely
like that's not an excuse that you're
allowing yourself that's why you just
shared it with all of us
and i'm proud of you for that because
it's an excuse everything's an excuse
yeah if you let it for sure like this is
more about you
what i'm trying to figure out is is
as the ultimate taster
do you have the stomach to grit [ __ ]
you don't like for enough of a period of
time to get to the place that you need
to get to
let me give you an example let me give
you an example of mahogany i have big
goals
right big dreams big aspirations on
impact
and success vayner media itself
is me grinning it because i didn't need
to build a business where i had clients
yelling
at me and all the [ __ ] i deal with
and you don't make a lot of money but i
knew i needed to build the foundation
and so in the prime of my career where i
had a ton of options
to have it more fun i decided to
eat [ __ ] i'm eating [ __ ] right now
with all the leverage i'm curious
how much [ __ ] you're willing to eat
and that's where i feel like there's
been a perspective switch like i said
since i left my corporate job which i
was very i am
still very grateful for it um but just
if it's me doing like the five six
different things that
i'm choosing to do and i'm eating [ __ ]
doing those five six different things
yes yeah long run i will do it for sure
because yeah i mean
and even even like further further
further down the line kind of goal i
have is
to become a chiropractor because you
know look
you know listen i listen you could be a
motivational
speaking chiropractor you can do
whatever you want
your your your biggest vulnerability at
this point from a very short
jam session that we're having is you
need meat
you need to have a singular thing that
gives you a foundational beginning
point i think the reason you can do six
things
is to your point if you get a nine to
five as
a receptionist in a chiropractor's
office because one day you want to be
that and you'll learn through osmosis
and you'll make relationships
but that starts to give you the
financial foundation to actually move
out
because you said that was your goal you
could live in your parents your whole
life i think it's [ __ ] fresh
i'm starting to think that i want to do
that like it's so fun but
but you need to realize
that you need a foundational piece
and then you need to let all your other
chaos happen i have a foundational piece
mahogany i don't want to tell people how
much time i'm spending on sports cards
right now
i'm on [ __ ] ebay 24 hours a day like
i'm in it
but it's the meat that is allowing me to
be
oh [ __ ] i'm hot on sports cards for six
years because this is the moment
[ __ ] i'm gonna go you know uh start a
sneaker deal with k
swiss empathy wines vayner sports
still great you know
all that comes with having the
foundation you need a foundation
and without it you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna struggle i'm telling you
you're gonna struggle
eat a singular thing i would make that
thing very strategic to all of your
other ambitions
why can't you be the cr why can't you be
the art director
for one of the 50 biggest motivational
speakers in the world you clearly have
artistic talent
right why can't you be the creative on
you know you're in atlanta why don't you
reach out to sarah blakely who's a
[ __ ] g
she's the founder of spanx her husband
jesse itzler is a vayner speaker speaker
he's a g created go new york go new york
oh that song for the knicks back in 94
and many other businesses and books and
all that why can't you reach out to her
and say
i want to do creative for you because
now you're in the osmosis
in the cocoon of a motivational speaker
and a business speaker and a g
female who lives in atlanta like that's
how you have to think
that's a good 45 50 60 000 a year job
for you
because it gets you to move out and you
start saving a little bit
and you're making relationships and
you're a young woman and you can do all
those things over the next 40 years
i love it i love it too yeah
i'm so down i'm listen to me you will
lose
i'm telling you i'm telling you with all
the love of my heart you will lose
unless you right now use this moment
that you manifested through action
you didn't [ __ ] you know people are
like how do i get on tv i read the
comments as we speak
how do i get onto the character go on
twitter ask me
like follow to text me on 212-931-5731
and ask me people like how how well how
do i do that it's called google
[ __ ] google it
figure it out you figured out how to get
on this show
you need to figure out how to get you a
real stable job that pays you enough to
do the things you want that you like
enough but is strategic
for what you want to do in life what you
did to get on this show
was action notificating i want to retire
my parents
i want to chiropract i want to like you
need action
but i think the practical execution is
action
that is strategic to your wants i love
those wants i'm not when i just did that
whole thing i'm not dissing your wants
i'm fired up about your wants
i just want you to get something
practical as [ __ ] right
that is foundational foundation
to get to those places work nine to
[ __ ] six for sarah blakely or some
other
you know per person that you want to be
like
in [ __ ] atlanta which is unlimited
[ __ ] g's in atlanta
and then at you know 7 8 9
10 11 p.m do side things art
you know
but you don't have the stake i don't
and you might be too cozy with the
infrastructure you have
it might be nice to have mom help out
with the little one i get it i have
empathy i'm not [ __ ] judging
i get [ __ ] but you need to figure [ __ ]
out for you
for sure i completely agree
you said to me i want to [ __ ] retire
my parents i want to move out you need
[ __ ] money
yes very true i want you to get a job
that pays you money
but is also strategic to all the
wonderful energy that you have
you get it yes that's it
not maybe i'll love teaching special
needs kids
maybe i'll love being you know maybe
nothing
things to know what really resonates
with me
you need to go work for a motivational
speaker or a chiropractor period and a
story i'm ending it with that i got to
go i love you see it back
please please please yes can mahogany
studios got it
all right justin get us out of here bye
thank you everybody
lebanon big love for all of you all of
our hearts and prayers
are with everybody from the incredible
city of beirut uh
i i really genuinely enjoyed all of you
in the uh
in the comments today please hit me up
on twitter right now garyvee on twitter
right now
and tell me what's good